a big winner of the day yanni pogbachie
you've incorporated the catalan as part
of your repertoire with huge success how
did it feel today
well
better than yesterday
yeah a little bit more successful a
little bit more successful you would say
were you surprised about his very long
thing here in this position were you
familiar with the position that we got
after rook b1
well i think he uh quite recently had a
game against magnus and where he chose
this a696
so
maybe in zagreb okay i know no idea but
uh okay one of the recent rapid games
uh but i felt like uh this is
probably not the most
expected line
in the catalan out of like
three or four extremely solid lines so i
just had an idea so then i sacrificed
the pawn like queen situated and
played for rhino for some compensation
and yeah in fact it's quite a playable
line for white of course like black is
solid but
yeah i think he
played like i mean it's in an
interesting way but maybe some of his
decisions were like
questionable take us through some of
those decisions where do you think he
started to lose the threat of the
position clearly this is still playable
he's under pressure bar up a pawn where
does where do the wheels start coming
off i can't recall maybe there is
suddenly bishop e7 move is important to
me instead of bishop d6 so it's
uh i i think yeah after movement of 12 i
think bishop i think we should be seven
yeah with some weird ideas maybe queen
protects the pawn on h7 and then you
make a castle like this like we should
be signing queen h5 yeah because for
example here after bishop d6 maybe
bishop is um you know gets into trouble
after c4 c5 white for instant tempi yeah
uh so there was a game that went queen
h5 actually exactly in this position
yeah that's maybe a good move
were you surprised by f5
uh no it he took like a long thing and i
thought like maybe it would be queen if
i queen h5 or h6 or f5 so after 5 i
wasn't sure like how do i uh how to
proceed here so bishop g2 was the move
yeah
yeah and here i was kind of expecting
inspecting e5
which they just was the best move yeah i
thought it's like e5 is very principal
actually f5 i didn't really see the way
so rook b7 is quite tempting but after
rook b7 i think he can
not take on b7 but he can just go e4 so
if we're cutting up the bishop
yeah so that's not so clear if i
achieved something yeah so probably
instead of rook b7 i would i would
choose uh maybe just taking on b7 here
always the bishop so now i have this
champion for queen b3 check i'm not sure
i'm
massively better or something but
clearly okay i have sort of an upper
hand here so it's like some b file but
once again black is very solid
and what he did uh
well i don't i don't really know uh so
he made a castle yeah here yeah we got
to this rook 10 game yeah the rook game
i felt like it was very suspicious for
him because
he can't really get this um
i mean simple freon to structure yes so
basically the way how you draw this
horse in games you just try to
not to lose all your pawns or win as
much pawns opposing opponents in the end
as you can and then defend on the you
know on looking side three on two but
exactly this three on two is quite
unpleasant yeah so it's like uh we were
talking about that i'm not sure i'm not
sure it's winning
with the best play but uh i mean anyway
what he did
what he did was quite
quite hard for me to understand because
he decided to stay
uh in a very like in a very common way
and yeah after the game he said that
okay he
didn't really see a plan for me to
improve it which was
quite surprising because uh okay you
have no plan i just can push pawns here
so
that's a good maybe maybe one one
candidate called you know
can't call this a plane yeah but yeah
that's
it worked in this game so it has to be a
good ocean baby yeah
i thought maybe g4 is more is more
precise but i felt like okay 5 k4 should
also be more or less enough
uh i mean okay computer you know has
always been in the world
so
well it's hard to say what was next
because yeah he just stayed until i
actually put my king somewhere
somewhere on e6 and this was yeah i
think this was enough there was some
time that i thought about you only in a
very dynamic way you loved all these
complications and suddenly you add this
cation you outplay perugia positionally
simply having a better understanding of
structures do you think that you've been
able to adapt to other types of chess i
think i'm still
you know still learning with this type
of chess but saying of the
all the way i mean of course of course
one can only dream about such an end
game i mean especially this rook ending
with
when you have some pawn majority and
also an active rookies yeah even despite
its equal number of pawns it's still
like
i mean it's uh
it's really hard to play uh as a as a
weaker side
i have to ask you what happened
yesterday
uh i thought like maybe
you know the other only good news about
yesterday's games was like it's it's
really hard to play wars
uh so i was quite optimistic about
today's game uh because of this but
actually yeah i think i just
had not enough experience uh into these
type of structures and uh thanks to
magnus i got some
yeah probably i would prefer like get it
like somewhere before but
uh i mean yeah it's like type of
position which is
white is uh i don't know
uh pretends to you know to improve but
in fact it's very hard to improve hawaii
but
yeah i guess uh just
when it's like five different lines
saying zero zero zero of computer rights
of course uh play could be improved from
both sides you know especially in the
opening but i mean of course the c5 uh
i mean it could have it could only have
sense when when i don't trade away my
knight on e6 then i have this tactical
idea c5 d4 and then my knight becomes
active
but as it was in the game
yeah i guess he just uh
uh he just got some some nice two
bishops and turkey this b4b5 idea and uh
yeah it also was based on some blunder
because after bishop d2 i was going to
play 94.
and then okay and notice that okay
bishop b5 b6 bishop p1 and uh yeah my
position just falls apart
so
that's why i mean okay of course one
could defend it better for example
player okay eight instead of whatever
key seven and it's like it's worse uh
it's much worse but it's i mean far from
losing
but yeah it's not uh as you know it's
the same rush it was not you know back
from the day
well yeah i'm always learning the panel
do you guys have any questions
not just
nice balance back victory yeah i don't
want to say that those are those are
good interviews to have back-to-back
yeah
congratulations and uh ian i will look
forward to your game tomorrow